je viens de dire le nouveau gouvernement
a fait son entrée au sein de l'hémicycle
et oui on l'attendait depuis longtemps
cette première séance de questions au
gouvernement sait déjà que à les
secrétaires d'état seront nommés la
semaine prochaine mais c'était bien
l'entrée de jeu aujourd'hui on peut dire
que cette première séance de questions
au gouvernement s'est déroulée de
manière plutôt énergique puisqu'on a pu
voir un jean castex parler d'une voix
forte posez sûrement pour asseoir son
autorité de celui qui était quasiment
inconnu dans le monde politique et du
grand public il ya encore quelques jours
alors il a été bien évidemment
questionné sur la réforme des retraites
pour lui pas question de faire marche
arrière cette réforme des retraites de
voix devra voir le jour tel que l'a
décidé le président emmanuel macron il a
également parlé de la relance économique
je veillerai personnellement à ce que le
gouvernement puisse travailler de façon
solidaire fin de citation et puis eric
dupond-moretti également le nouveau
ministre de la justice a été interpellé
par l'opposition l'opposition qui le
fustigeait du fait qu'il ya encore
quelques mois il se disait très
défavorable à un poste au gouvernement
en disant que si on le lui proposait il
refuserait et qu'il ne ferait jamais de
politique et bien visiblement il a
changé d'avis et il invite le
gouvernement à ne pas le juger de
manière trop hâtive je vous propose de
l'écouter
d'abord vous savez tous que quand on est
avocat pénaliste libre on n'a pas la
même parole que quand on représente
l'état ce n'est chappe à personne on ne
juge pas des hommes sur des a priori me
semble-t-il
vous me jugerez sur ce que j'ai fait
quand je leur ai fait quand on est haut
quand on est au café du commerce on ne
s'exprime pas alors comme quand on est
avocat
quand on est avocat on ne s'exprime pas
comme quand on les ministres ça c'est
pour la forme
moi au 15 mai au café du commerce je ne
porte pas de cravate à l'assemblée j'en
ai une
j'ai vécu la commission d' enquête
parlementaire d'outreau à ma gauche il y
avait si vous me permettez ce mauvais
jeu de mots le député marceau monsieur
houillon monsieur vallini sensibilités
politiques différentes
82 propositions on peut tous travailler
ensemble
voilà maryse et monsieur v
voilà une réaction très énergique de la
part du nouveau ministre de la justice
et puis barbara pompili la ministre à
l'écologie s'est exprimé aussi en
appelant les députés à se rappeler de ce
qui avait été fait de positif et puis à
la sortie de l'hémicycle nous avons pu
nous entretenir quelques secondes avec
jean luc mélenchon qui nous a fait part
d'une certaine lassitude de sa part et
de son bord politique je vous propose de
l'écouter
je ressens une certaine lassitude
rabâchage permanent d'une formule
magique d'après laquelle il suffirait
que on salit pour que le problème soit
réglé
non c'est un peu plus compliqué j'ai
aussi incertaine your avoir maintenant
des ailés de l'union que j'ai connu
beaucoup moins et les quand il y avait
vraiment l'union donc j'ai appris avec
la longueur du temps et de l'expérience
politique à mettre à distance certaine
dose impatience voilà à noter également
l'absence du ministre de l'intérieur le
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin peut-être pour une question
d'agenda
en tout cas le gouvernement se rendra
désormais au sénat où une séance
l'attend à 15 heures
kevin merci pour ces précisions
[Musique]